some of my critics when I showed up to
the University of Pittsburgh tried to
blow me up which I find very impolite I
think that was very wrong of them to do
a couple of antifa operatives showed up
to this appearance I had at pit and they
they burned me an effigy and they set
the street on fire and then they threw
an explosive at the venue when I started
to walk on stage which was not a very
warm welcome in fact it was a very warm
welcome it was a burning hot welcome but
it was not very nice so when I received
this invitation to Cornell I feared I
might face a similar scene Cornell after
all is one of the early hubs of leftist
violence on campus the Takeover of
Willard straight Hall in 1969 is
probably the most infamous such incident
in American history I'm sure that
everybody in this room knows about the
Takeover for those of you at home who
are not familiar with it on April 19th
1969 rifle wielding black student
radicals stormed and occupied the
Willard straight Hall at this very
University evicting parents who had been
visiting their children for the weekend
and inflicting maximum reputational
damage on
Cornell why did the students take over
the hall according to the armed
occupiers the Takeover was a response to
reports of a burning cross at the warry
Student Center the night
before wh supremacists threatened black
students and so the black students
threatened back but it turns out that
the whole thing was fake news it was
Jesse Smet the prequel it was all just a
big
hoax itha police never managed to track
down those elusive cross burners and
they suspected that the afroamerican
Society members themselves set the blaze
in order to justify further protests
this thesis was not just the result of
knee-jerk
Prejudice one member of the afroamerican
society later seemed to confirm it
Steven Goodwin a Cornell student who was
the treasurer of the afroamerican
society called the cross burning quote a
setup the society had contrived The hoax
according to Goodwin quote to bring more
media and more attention to the whole
thing now such hoaxes have become
commonplace what did the radicals want
the chief demand was the creation of an
Africana studies Department Africana
studies like virtually all of the
studies departments is a pseudo academic
discipline that replaces liberal
education aimed at discovering truth and
disciplining the will and intellect with
training in political activism that
undermines a student's education by
encouraging a radical skepticism that
denies the very possibility of
discerning truth thereby degrading
politics from a rational Endeavor into a
battle of irrational
will before the student paper calls me
racist I'm sure that the pens are
already a flutter with that accusation
please rest assured that I feel the same
way about all of the critical studies
departments whether we're talking about
queer studies or women's studies or even
American studies the only difference
between American studies and all of the
other critical studies departments is
that American studies is the only
studies that hates its own subject so
queer studies loves queers women's
studies loves women at least as long as
they're feminist black studies loves
black people only American studies hates
its subject which is America but I
digress I could go on about that all day
long the great Economist and social
writer Thomas Soul who is 93 years young
and still sharp as attack Thomas Soul
one of the great one of the great living
American intellects he took an even
tougher view of the motives for the
Takeover Thomas Soul who had joined the
Cornell faculty four years prior right
before the Willard straigh Hall takeover
he observed that the white president of
Cornell had quote sought to increase
minority student enrollment and to do so
by admitting students who would not meet
the existing academic standards at
Cornell which meant that in Soul's words
quote the emphasis was on getting
militant ghetto kids some of whom turned
out to be hoodlums who terrorized other
black students in addition to provoking
a racial backlash among
whites this is of course exactly what
happened had Cornell hired faculty and
accepted students without lowering
standards had the newly recruited black
population of Cornell been made up
entirely of Thomas Souls there Never
Would Have Been A Willard straight hole
takeover and there never would have been
a creation of this pseudo academic
department and the students would have
been required as they previously had
been to get an education if they wanted
to
graduate the black activism was the most
visible but the same pattern applied to
all of the other supposedly grieved
groups that demanded special treatment
thereby lowering the standards for
everyone and producing now multiple
generations of Highly credentialed
extraord ordinarily ignorant
radicals today sadly but not
surprisingly some of the Cornell
Administration seems to look back on the
school's greatest shame with
indifference at best and more often with
pride the official Cornell website reads
quote within Cornell the Takeover has
come to be seen as an event that gave
birth to enormous social governance and
ideological change it's a very
diplomatic way of putting it a headline
linked on the website reads quote a
campus takeover that symbolized an era
of change with AK-47s evicting parents
from their rooms yes the change of the
American University not just Cornell not
just the IB League virtually all of them
from institutions of Higher Learning for
producing educated citizens into radical
indoctrination factories for producing
ignorant activists the New Perspective
is no
coincidence the radicals won the campus
fights of the 1960s and they now run
those universities as tenured radicals
to borrow a phrase from Roger Kimble
today according to a number of surveys
some 24% of college professors in the
social sciences call themselves radical
21% call themselves activists 18% call
themselves
marxists The the ratio of liberal to
conservative professors according to
another survey is 8 to1 in polyi that's
pretty bad it's 17:1 in history
departments it's 44:1 in sociology it's
48 to1 in English and it's 108 to zero
in race and gender
studies I don't really know how that one
works I was not a math major but I
suppose I would even think it might be
higher as my friend Chris rufo pointed
out in his excellent new book America's
cultural revolution the most prominent
leaders of the radical student movements
of the 1960s I'm thinking of Bill SS the
leader of the Weather Underground uh
which was a terror group for those of
you too young to remember uh Angela
Davis a communist terrorist who plotted
a an attack a kidnapping that left four
people dead including a judge those
people and many others ended up with
kushy University
cures meanwhile the radicalism
spreads yet again on Cornell's campus
which just last week saw the arrest of a
student who was threatening to kill all
the
Jews just my
luck I survive antifa at the University
of Pittsburgh and I end up at Cornell
with Hamas what are the odds all the way
up in Ithaca I didn't think they could
get this far up
the student Behind These threats Patrick
Dy D is a little on the nose if you ask
me apparently posted notes to an online
discussion site threatening to quote
shoot up 104 West which seems to be the
kosher dining hall as well as to stab
and slit the throat of any Jewish men he
found on campus and to do all sorts of
terrible things to Jewish women that he
found on campus and to behead Jewish
babies before finally threatening to
quote bring an assault rifle to campus
and shoot all you pig
Jews this is not good the liberal media
did not quite know how to react to the
threats because the threats did not fit
the pre-written
narrative if a student threatens Jews on
campus that student is supposed to be a
skinhead Neo-Nazi he's ideally going to
be one who voted for Donald Trump best
of all he would be one who listens to a
lot of conservative media all of whom
can then be vilified after the incident
short of that the student should at
least be Arab Arabs were considered
white according to official government
documents for a lot of American History
so in that way the media could twist it
into the guy being like sort of white
kind of like a George Zimmerman after
the killing of Trayvon Martin George
Zimmerman was reported the guy is as
Hispanic as they come they said he well
he's a white hispanic you know he's very
he leans white anyway he identifies as
white he transracial I don't know
then then the liberal media could at
least blame white people for
perpetuating the islamophobia that drove
this hypothetically Muslim student to
threaten to kill all the Jews all that
would have worked fine for the
narrative but when the threats come from
a random Asian guy the liberal Elite has
no idea what to
do even conservatives might be a little
confused over how to react after all
conservatives have spent the past seven
or eight years at least describing
ourselves as the Defenders of free
speech Free Speech absolutists some have
called themselves not me but some of
them have done that but of course
threats have never been protected speech
in this country or in any sensible
country for that matter neither has
liable neither has
obscenity for much of American History
we had laws against blasphemy in many
parts of this country no one ever
considered that to be some grave
violation of the First
Amendment the principles of free speech
even John Lock who is one of the most
articulate Defenders of free speech ever
he's the father of liberalism even lock
argued in the letter concerning
Toleration that atheists should not be
afforded Free Speech or really any
rights at
all all societies have a right to
standards and in any case all societies
have standards and enforce standards
whether they recognize some right to
them or
not I've mention this fact once or twice
that the the real debate here is not
between free speech and censorship but
between competing sets of Standards
grounded in in competing conceptions of
the good the true and the Beautiful I
will not belabor the point if you'd like
to hear more about it you can always get
it in my book speechless controlling
words controlling Minds you can order it
right now on your phones if you wanted
to we could take a moment pull up your
favorite book store app and order it or
you could order it after the
lecture all Society
have this right so my concern here is
not about any attacks on free speech
with this student being arrested for
making threats my concern with this
young man's arrest is not that the
police have gone too far in restricting
speech but that they have not gone far
enough because in addition to Jews
plenty of other politically
unfashionable people regularly face
threats on campus and the threat makers
often face no repercussions
whatsoever just off the top of my head
conservatives Christians PR lifers white
people even just mild critics of gender
ideology all regularly receive threats
including death threats from political
radicals and the threats they face are
not merely from Fringe cranks top
ranking Democrat politicians have
explicitly called for violence against
conservatives Congress lady Maxine
Waters has urged her followers to push
back on conservatives whenever they see
them in public to go to their homes
where their children
sleep kamla Harris and top staffers for
Joe Biden bailed BLM riers who had
targeted civilians out of prison Hillary
Clinton told her followers that it is
impossible to be civil with Republicans
and if history has taught us anything it
is that if Hillary Clinton threatens you
with vience you take that
seriously your life could depend on that
okay I'm kidding I'm kidding am I
kidding I'd bet the farm that some
prominent figure at this very university
has at some point proposed abolishing
whiteness or some other such nonsense it
is absolutely right to punish cranks who
threatened to kill innocent Jews it is
likewise right to punish the mainstream
leftists who threaten all the rest of us
I myself am not Jewish I am Catholic so
I suppose I am in a certain sense Jewish
to borrow a phrase from George
Santos we Catholics love God the Father
we love the Old Testament we crucially
took a different turn at the Incarnation
and crucifixion resurrection of our Lord
and at the Pentecost and The Descent of
the Holy Spirit but still in the words
of Pope pasus the 11th
spiritually we are semites and in light
of the present flash point for World War
III the horrific Hamas terror attack on
the state of Israel the subsequent
outbreak of war in the Middle East I
cannot help but notice some additional
coincidences additional similarities
between the conflict in the Middle East
and the conflict Americans see on the
home front every day immediately
following the Hamas attack of October
7th halfway across the world the black
lives matter organization in the United
States posted a Palestinian flag to its
social media account in the silhouette
of a
paraglider the meaning was clear not
only does BLM support Palestinian
civilians it supports Hamas as well not
only does BLM criticize certain policies
of the Israeli State as anyone might BLM
endorses the murder of more than 1,000
Israeli civilians women
children and the
elderly some were surprised that BLM
would endorse
Hamas I'm not sure why we all watched
for eight months as BLM rampaged
throughout the country burning looting
rioting and killing dozens of innocent
people that is who BLM is that is what
BLM does tactically Hamas and BLM are on
the same page at a deeper level LEL the
two Terror groups converge ideologically
as well because the argument made by
Hamas and its excuses and Defenders
against the state of Israel is precisely
the same argument made by BLM and antifa
and other leftist groups against the
United States and the West more broadly
namely that we are colonizers and
settlers who are oppressing beleaguered
racial and ethnic and religious
minorities who have a supposedly more
legitimate claim to the
land one need not blindly support the
Israeli government to recognize that the
arguments against the state of Israel do
not bode well for us either one need not
accede to the religious and historical
claims of Zionism or the wisdom of the
Balor declaration or even the Prudence
of the establishment of the state in
1948 to recognize that the argument
Advanced against the state of Israel
today is precisely the same argument
Advanced by many of the same people
against our own country as
well one need not understand any of the
nuances of this extremely complex
conflict to notice that all the worst
people in American politics Rashida
Talib AOC all the rest of them all
support broadly the Palestine Liberation
movement one does not need a degree in
political science to understand that
people who tend to be wrong about
everything might also be wrong about
this as
well that the enemy of my enemy is often
my friend so what are we supposed to do
about it what is the American interest
as we stand on the brink of World War II
the American interest it seems to me is
not to go over the precipice the
American interest is to contain the war
to contain the war does not necessarily
mean a ceasefire as many on the left or
demand in a ceasefire in which Hamas
continues to control Gaza would seem to
be not only an unacceptable security
risk for the state of Israel but also
more relevant to our national concerns a
recipe for more and expanded fighting
the part that seems most relevant for us
is that the recent decline of the United
States and the rise of China China to
quote the former and perhaps future
president raises the prospect of global
war to an extremely high level
as the political scientist Graham
Allison has observed of the 16 most
recent examples of a rising power
confronting an established Global power
War resulted in all but four cases
contrary to what foreign policy Geniuses
like Joe Biden told us when they
promoted the growth of China as a rising
tide that lifts All Ships Come on Jack
come
on Corn Pop this will this will raise
everybody up that is not exact actly
what happened a rising tide does not
always lift all boats in international
relations when a rising tide lifts a
nation to challenge a great power 75% of
the time it leads to
war that is the most pressing reason
that the US position Visa the war in the
Middle East and the war in Ukraine you
remember the war in Ukraine that was the
big story it was always the great fight
for democracy until like a week ago and
then that just totally dropped off the
headlines the other reason to contain
the war is a more fundamental
conservative
observation our individual stocks of
Reason are small and events can quickly
spin out of control and it's much easier
to destroy than to build American
adventurism overseas has rarely worked
out well for us and over the past half
century it has been disastrous things
have not turned out the way grandiose
self-appointed Grand strategists have
told us that they would to get a sense
of the complexity consider this recent
example this is an alert that I got from
my Wall Street Journal app about three
days
ago
Russia Russia which the left used to
love but now hates is indirectly funding
Hezbollah a Theocratic terror group that
you might expect the left to hate but
which it now loves because Hezbollah
attacks Israel which the left used to
support but now hates because it
considers Israel a colonial extension of
the West which the left now hates and
which created the modern nation state of
Israel but now also hates it then Israel
for its part meanwhile has armed aeran
which is a Muslim country carrying out a
genocide of the Armenians Armenia being
the oldest Christian country in the
world even though Israel often sides
with the Christians against the Muslims
but in this case the Muslims in aeran
appro Iran and Iran is Israel's Chief
enemy and in war the enemy of of one's
enemy is often one's friend are you
confused join the club man I'm pretty
confused
too the enmities and the justifications
for these conflicts Israel versus
Palestine Armenia versus aeran Ukraine
versus Russia go back centuries even
Millennia unless you think that you have
finally solved conflicts considered
intractable for decades and centuries
restrained in American war seems to be
prudent which brings me to my broader
point a point that applies to War as
well as to domestic politics actions as
well as speech for most of History
conservatives have been the party of
Restraint of limits of humility and
Prudence Prudence considered by
Aristotle the Paramount political virtue
this reputation suffered a wee little
bit of damage in the mid 2000s thanks to
the rise of the neoconservatives of the
Bush era who advocated an ambitious
downright wilsonian foreign policy that
never saw a foreign Backwater that it
did not want to bomb and Conquer but the
aberration of the wilsonian right has
receded once again in recent years
Donald Trump for instance campaigned on
restraint on avoiding war and focusing
on the home front and to the surprise of
his critics Trump conducted the finest
foreign policy in at least a quarter of
a century maybe longer I sometimes think
of my relatives who I've lost you know
who died say 15 20 years ago I think how
would I explain to them that that Donald
Trump the this yes the real estate guy
yeah no yeah the star of that reality
show the game show on NBC yeah he he's
president he became president and uh he
was great actually he was like a better
foreign policy president than just about
I don't think that he would not believe
me and yet it happened I could say Trump
bought brought peace to the Middle East
that that is a sentence you almost
shouldn't be able to utter and yet and
yet it worked how's that possible Donald
Trump doesn't know anything about
foreign
policy I think actually that's part of
the explanation Trump's lack of foreign
policy wonk bonafides seems to have
served him pretty well perhaps because
he never thought that he had all the
answers and he consistently preferred
modest victories to grandiose
conquests the does not respect any such
limits moral political even
biological the left advances an ideology
of total Liberation from all constraints
not only do they Advocate Liberation
from the political order they take this
campaign of total Revolution to its
logical conclusion as they campaign for
the liberation of the self from the body
which of course is impossible through
transgender ideology and that issue
fires them up more than any other
of all the things they could attack me
for that's what they're screaming about
outside this room there is a perverse
coherence to the left's false and
prideful vision of the world the nation
and even the human person just as there
is a humble consistency in the
conservative
Vision a line from the British political
philosopher Michael Oak shot comes to
mind as relevant to you me and World War
I to be conservative Oak shot writes is
to prefer the familiar to the unknown to
prefer the tried to the untried fact to
mystery the actual to the possible the
limited to the unbounded the near to the
distant the sufficient to the super
abundant the convenient to the perfect
present laughter to utopian Bliss thank
you very much